-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
I am your host,
Shipwrecked Jimmy Fallon.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I finally did it --
I went through puberty.
Yeah.
Really cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I like it. Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Yes, I've grown a beard,
and, yes,
this definitely won't help with
people confusing me for
Jimmy Kimmel.
I want to get to the point
where I can annoy people
by taking out a tiny beard comb
at the dinner table.
But enough about me.
What a show we have
for you today.
Hillary and Chelsea Clinton
are my guests tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
That's right.
Right now, Hillary's on her
nationwide "I Told You So" tour.
Well, guys,
let's get to some news.
Yesterday, President Biden
was delivering a speech
in Wisconsin where he
was interrupted by a heckler.
Can we see the
president's response?
-By the way --
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Alright! God love you.
Let him go.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, don't --
Let him go.
Let him -- He's --
Look, everybody's entitled
to be an idiot.
No, no,
everybody's entitled, okay?
-"Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
♪♪
No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no."
Everyone's entitled to be
an idiot.
Yeah, that sounds like something
your mom would say
after your dad insists
he can fix the dishwasher.
Yeah. "Everyone's entitled
to be an idiot.
Go ahead."
"You put this, uh --
Put that..."
I also am pretty sure
that's the first insult to ever
start with the phrase
"God love you."
No, no, no, no, no.
After a few more
seconds of heckling,
security was like,
"Okay, that's enough, Mr. Trump.
Please -- Just please."
Yep, Biden wasn't pulling
any punches yesterday.
He also went after
far-right Republicans
and referred to them
as "Trumpies."
Trumpies sounds like
a breakfast cereal
that's all marshmallows.
Right? You want some Trumpies?
Trumpies sounds like
a word for when
a toddler gets grumpy
on a train.
Like, "Uh-oh, he's got a little
case of the Trumpies."
Trumpies sounds like
something you catch from
hooking up in a hot tub.
"Hey, I just found out
I have Trumpies.
You should
get yourself checked."
Speaking of
the former president,
a federal judge unsealed
the list of materials
seized from Mar-a-Lago,
and it revealed that Trump
had classified documents
mixed in with
newspaper clippings,
magazines, and clothing.
Even T.J.Maxx was like, "Dude,
get it together in there."
That's right --
Trump had classified documents
mixed in with
newspaper clippings, magazines,
photographs, and even clothing,
but right now,
millions of people
are still defending Trump.
[ Glass shatters ]
What was that?
-Oh, nothing -- nothing, Jimmy.
I just found your monologue
very funny tonight.
That's all. Just keep telling
your funny jokes.
-Oh, yeah. I will.
Thank you. Thank you.
Meanwhile, a judge just
granted Trump's request
for a special master
to review all the documents
seized from Mar-a-Lago,
which could massively delay
the Justice Department's
investigation into
the former president.
[ Glass shatters ]
-[ Stammers ]
-Can we get her a paper cup?
Get her paper cups in there.
Did I mention Hillary Clinton
is on the show tonight?
Hillary Clinton and Chelsea.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right --
the special master has to review
over 11,000 documents, which
could delay the investigation.
Man, only Trump could avoid
jail just because
there's too much evidence.
Switching gears,
after two failed attempts
to launch their new moon rocket,
NASA has postponed the mission
until at least next month.
Even more annoying, they still
texted the moon, "There in 15."
No, you're not.
You're not gonna be here.
Some entertainment news.
I saw that a British reboot of
the reality show "Survivor"
is coming to the BBC.
It's gonna be even harder than
the American version.
The contestants
will be stranded on an island
with nothing but
unlimited British food.
Some more TV news.
Amazon just debuted
their new show
"The Lord of the Rings:
The Rings of Power."
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's good.
And HBO has their new show
"House of the Dragon."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's very confusing,
which probably explains
the commercial I just saw today.
Watch this.
-Hey, fantasy fans,
if you love J.R.R. Tolkien,
then you'll love "Lord of the
Rings: The rings of power."
And if you love
George R.R. Martin,
then you'll love
"House of the Dragon."
They sound similar, but "Lord of
the Rings: The Rings of Power"
is based on
"Lord of the Dragons,"
and "House of the Ring"
is based on "Game of Rings."
One was written by
G.R.R. Markien,
the other by Tolk R.R. Dragon.
Only Amazon's got
"Ring Lord: Power of the the,"
while only HBO's got
"Drag House."
Sunday nights are for
"House of Pancakes,"
and Thursdays are for
"Ring of the Ring:
The R.R. of House.
So sit back and enjoy
Hulu's Showtime original,
"Dragon of the House: Ring Dings
and the Sorcerer's Stone,"
based on the novels by
R.L. Stine.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's just...
So much good stuff.
Hey, guys, I read that an
E. coli outbreak
linked to the lettuce at Wendy's
has now spread to
six different states
and sickened 97 people.
Ooh, yeah.
Meanwhile, Chipotle heard that
and was like, "97?
Please, we do that in a day."
I heard about a dog
at an airport in Italy
who made a pretty big discovery.
Take a look at this.
-A drug-sniffing dog
at a Milan, Italy, airport
found more than 30 pounds
of cocaine in a wheelchair.
The narcotics were stuffed into
the chair's leather upholstery.
Authorities say the suspect
immediately stood up
from the wheelchair
and was arrested.
[ Laughter ]
-Yep. The guy stood up like,
"It's a miracle!
I don't believe it."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, finally,
it is Tuesday, guys.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ "WeTweet" ♪
♪ "WeTweet" ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show
you five different tweets,
and we're all going to
vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have your
voting clickers at your seats.
I can tell right there
by the confusion.
There you go.
Like, "No, that's your clicker."
You can all vote for --
You can vote for all of them
if you want to.
You can vote for none of them.
I just want to you to have fun.
And then we're going to see
the results live.
Higgins, Roots, you all
have your clickers, as well?
-Ready, clicking away.
-Good.
Roots, nice to see you.
Whichever tweet
gets the most likes,
I will tweet it out live
on the show
during the commercial break,
and then you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a shared experience.
Alright, you guys ready?
Here we go.
The first tweet is...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
When it's not you, yeah.
Alright.
Cast your vote,
thumbs up, thumbs down.
The votes are in. Let's go.
Let's just see
the results right here.
-Whoa!
-Whoa, not bad!
157.
-Wow.
-I feel good about that one.
-157 -- that's good.
-Very positive group
here tonight.
I like these guys.
The next one is...
♪♪
Sit, sit.
Sit.
Sit. Good boy.
Sit. Alright.
-I'm going to say not as good.
-I'm going to say
not as good on this one.
-Yeah.
-I like it, but I don't think --
-It's a valid point.
-Yeah, if we were playing
a different game.
-Yeah, I mean, a different game,
it'd be like --
-Valid Point.
That is a valid point.
-Dogs should exercise, yeah.
-That's correct.
-But this is a different game.
-Let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh, my God.
-Yeah. Wow!
-Wow.
-Knockout punch.
-Very honest audience.
Yeah, very honest.
They were giving
and then they --
They giveth
and they taketh away, yeah.
Alright, let's look at
this next one. It says...
That was a mistake.
Exhausted.
-Yeah.
-He's a great actor.
-Wow!
-One of the greatest actors
of all time.
Legendary actor.
-But you don't want your baby --
-No, no, no.
You don't want --
tired Gene Hackman.
Let's see the results
on this one here.
[ Drumroll ]
Alright, okay. Not bad.
-Wow.
-I love that the audience
is that honest.
They really are like, "Yeah,
I'm not going
to give it to you.
No."
You think it'd all be
200, 200-0.
No, the people are making
a choice here.
-Yeah.
They love Gene Hackman.
Next up, have this one.
♪♪
"It can go up --
It can go 150 feet above --
It can go 60 miles
on one charge.
You can --"
Like, "Yeah, yeah. Who cares?"
Let's see the results
on this one.
[ Drumroll ]
-Oh! That's shocking.
-Airport still --
-Airport still by five.
-Yeah. Because when you see
people running through, it's --
-I know.
-And sometimes,
the one wheel comes off,
and then you got to re--
You got to try to
figure out both wheels.
The one wheel goes off,
the Rollerblade wheel,
and then it's like, "Aah!"
Then it's turning, and then
you -- Yeah, you're in trouble.
Alright, this last one.
Yeah, I think that one's going
to be the winner, I think.
-You think airport or this one?
-I see this one here,
and I'm gonna say airport.
-Okay.
They all can't be winners, man.
-Yeah, I know, man.
-They all cannot be winners.
-Here we go.
It's a fun game either way.
-Yeah.
-Here's the last one here.
It says...
♪♪
-It's something --
-Some knew it, but --
-My kids would love that one.
-Your kids would dig that one.
-That's a valid point. Yeah.
-No, no,
we're not playing Valid Point.
-Oh, I thought we were
playing Valid Point.
-That is not the game
we're playing.
We're not playing Valid Point.
-That "sit," and this one --
-No, no, it's not Valid Point.
"Dinnerables" --
it's got to beat 157.
I think not,
but let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh, there we go right there!
I like it.
I'm happy with "airport."
Thank you all very much.
The winner is number one,
"airport," right there.
Seeing someone else run
is fun as hell.
I'm going post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like, give it a
"WeTweet," and enjoy.